while it's really easy to be upset when
directors chop cool-sounding scenes out
of our favorite movies the reality is
that deleted scenes are a necessity but
every once in a while a deleted scene is
uncovered that completely alters our
perception of a film in fact it could be
argued that some of the most legendary
scenes to ever hit the cutting room
floor would have actually improved the
films they were removed from join us as
we uncover the very best deleted scenes
that deserve to be pulled out of the
trash and given their own time to shine
in the spotlight aliens after surviving
the events of alien Ellen Ripley wakes
up in the sequel to discover that she
spent 57 years traveling in hypersleep
audiences who saw the original
theatrical cut of aliens assume that
ripley shrugs this ordeal off for the
most part but a deleted scene that ended
up in the 1992 special edition reveals
how the psychological impact of this
experience hurt our heroine far more
than anyone ever realized
following her awakening Ripley meets
company rep Carter Burke and asks about
her daughter insisting on answers after
some hesitation Burke reluctantly
reveals that her daughter died two years
earlier at the age of 66 upon seeing a
photograph of Amanda Ripley aged beyond
recognition Sigourney Weaver's heroine
has overcome with shock and grief in
hindsight it's hard to understand why
director James Cameron chose to remove
this scene in the first place not only
does the loss of Ripley's daughter help
contextualise the subsequent bond that
she forms with Newt but it also serves
as a stunning showcase of Weaver's
acting ability x-men first class in 2011
x-men first class rebooted the mutant
franchise in the process revealing how
the central relationship between Charles
Xavier and Erik Lehnsherr came to be
with that in mind it made perfect sense
to see these two bitter rivals initially
become friends however we didn't expect
to see Xavier telepathically alter the
perceptions of a potential new student
to convince her that magneto was dressed
in women's clothing it's good isn't it
that's right the blu-ray edition of
first class revealed a deleted scene in
which
Michael Fassbender actually wore a wig
and dressed in drag while recruiting new
students
unfortunately this hilarious moment
never made it to cinemas but now that
it's come to light it's easy to see why
magneto eventually turned against his
old friend Terminator 2 Judgment Day
here's another example of James Cameron
dropping the ball on one of his most
popular movies in Terminator 2 Judgment
Day John Connor asks the Terminator
about his mechanical mind and discovers
that his newfound protector can learn
human behavior after being exposed to it
for prolonged periods of time however a
deleted scene found on the special
edition of t2 reveals that Skynet
limited the terminators processors to a
read-only function by default preventing
it from actually understanding human
behavior on a personal level cue a
visually stunning scene during which
John and his mother open up the
terminators skull to manually alter his
CPU was the problem the deleted scene
serves as yet another reminder of how
groundbreaking the visual effects were
in t2 but more importantly the
ramifications of what happened here pay
off later in the movie as the Terminator
displays empathy in the final scene Mean
Girls one of the defining moments of the
classic 2014 comedy Mean Girls is when
Katie breaks her crown at the end and
throws out the pieces to the other girls
who deserve the title of Spring Fling
Queen including frenemy Regina George at
the time audiences assumed Katie and
Regina hadn't yet made up following the
fight that culminated in that brutal bus
ordeal but a deleted scene reveals that
the pair did actually speak before the
prom trying to make this about you I'm
the one that got hit by the bus I'm
sorry about all the other step two okay
I'm going to forgive you
sure Regina is on pain medication in
this moment but it actually goes a long
way to help humanize her and also
further explains Katie's subsequent act
of kindness it's a shame that audiences
didn't see this conversation play out in
theaters but Mean Girls remains totally
fetched nonetheless stop trying to make
fetch happen it's not going to happen
Blade Runner the question of whether
Rick Deckard is a replicant has plagued
film lovers for decades however Blade
Runner director Ridley Scott in
sis the Deckard is an artificial beam
and he included a scene that arguably
proves this in his official director's
cut
in typical puzzling fashion the original
cut of Blade Runner includes a scene in
which Deckard finds an origami unicorn
during his escape with Rachel all
audiences know at this stage is that a
fellow Blade Runner named Jeff left this
behind for Deckard but the reason why is
unclear however in a deleted scene that
Scott included in later versions Deckard
dreams of a unicorn the suggestion here
is that gaff left this origami for him
because he knows Deckard's memories and
innermost thoughts how would he know
this because Deckard is a replicant and
these memories were implants the thing
John Carpenter's sci-fi horror classic
the thing has inspired debates
surrounding its protagonist and whether
he can be trusted by the film's in the
Antarctic base where pilot RJ McCready
has been sent as occupied by a
shape-shifting alien that impersonates
the people it kills in the final scene
McCready and fellow survivor child's are
the only two who remained leaving
audiences to guess whether one of them
is secretly the monster in disguise just
wait here
[Music]
see what happens in an alternate ending
it's revealed that the alien does in
fact survive escaping the antarctic base
in the form of a husky this deleted
scene strongly suggests that McCready
definitely did die no matter who the
monster was impersonating however this
still doesn't explain which survivor
held a deadly secret at the end of the
original theatrical cut but some
eagle-eyed fans noticed that child's
doesn't appear to be breathing in that
last scene
whereas McCready's icy breath can be
seen in the air suggesting the child's
isn't really human after all
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice with
director Zack Snyder trying to turn the
BCE you into a viable Cinematic Universe
a lot of Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice felt rushed at times characters
even seemed to possess knowledge that
should have been out of their reach
the most obvious example occurs toward
the end when an imprisoned Lex Luthor
alludes to an evil force that threatens
to destroy the earth
the bells already been rung
and they've heard it comic book fans
assumed that this ominous warning was
linked to Darkseid in some way and they
were right as his nephew Steppenwolf
arrived soon after to cause havoc for
our heroes in Justice League
but how did Superman's arch nemesis know
Steppenwolf would travel to earth in the
first place in the ultimate edition of
dawn of Justice a deleted seam set on
the Kryptonian ship Luthor captured
reveals that the megalomaniac
experienced direct contact with
Steppenwolf sure the character design
changed dramatically between films but
at least we finally know the truth about
what Luthor was talking about while
trapped in his cell I believe in truth
but I'm also a big fan of Justice Star
Wars Episode six Return of the Jedi
for decades audiences have argued over
the existence of numerous plot holes in
the Star Wars franchise the one that
arguably sticks out the most is why Luke
Skywalker was never told the true
identity of his father sure this
omission built impressive amounts of
tension between Skywalker and Darth
Vader but one has to question why
obi-wan Kenobi didn't tell him long
before the pair finally clashed in
battle well it turns out that Return of
the Jedi originally included another
line that explains exactly why Kenobi
originally withheld this vital
information and it's all because of Yoda
when Luke returns to Yoda's bedside one
last time the fuzzy green Jedi reveals
that he forbade Kenobi from telling him
the truth about Vader not only does this
deleted seem solve one of the most
troubling plot holes in the franchise it
also sheds new light on Kenobi's
relationship with Yoda and their power
dynamic Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Part 1 long before Voldemort
re-emerged to cause havoc in Harry
Potter's life the young wizard had to
deal with an evil far closer to home his
abusive aunt uncle and cousin who
adopted him following his parents deaths
it's easy to picture these characters
purely in terms of light and darkness
but a deleted scene removed from Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows Part 1
reminds us that every one contains
elements of both including Harry's rude
cousin Dudley Dursley I don't think I
stir space
Thanks
while it's unfortunate that this party
was cut it's still heartening that fans
eventually got to see this important
moment play out in live action
[Music]